قال رئيس وحده الزلازل وتقليل المخاطر في
تركيا اورهان تتار ان قشره الارض تعرضت
لهزات زلزاليه كبيره لمده دقيقتين
متواصلتين خلال الزلزلين اللذين ضربات
تركيا في السادس من الشهر الجاري واشار
الى ان التقارير المحدثه التي قدمها
باحثون في المناطق المنكوبه تؤكداح قشره
الارض باكثر من سبعه امتار
استمرت مده التاثير لهذين الزلزالين حوالي
دقيقتين ولهذا تعرضت قشره الارض لهزات
زلزاليه كبيره لدقيقتين متواصلتين وهذا
حدث بعمق ثمانيه الى عشره كيلو مترات
والمعلومات المقدمه من المناطق المنكوبه
حسب الدراسات السابقه التي انجزها عدد من
الباحثين ان التغير الحاصل في قشره الارض
هو ثلاثه الى اربعه امتار لكن معلومات
باحثين تؤكد ان التغير وصل الى سبعه امتار
وثلاثين سم وهذه ارقام كبيره جدا